and the whole Sufi path that we talked
about is often
clothed in the language of love so it is
a a loving Journey it starts from this
position of being a lovesick basically
of longing for your beloved you're being
separated from your beloved and wanting
to return to them to unite with them
again Rumi again in his in the famous
the opening to the masnavi which is I
forget the name the song of the read he
talks about the the sound of the Nay
flute as being a kind of Cry Of longing
because it's been
separated from the Reed bed as a kind of
metaphor for the human longing for
returning to God for from his beloved
whom he's been separated from